Sherlock who directed by the guy who
directed snatch strange pic okay so when
seeing the trailer I think it's safe to
say that Sherlock Holmes looked like it
was gonna be national treasure or the
League of Extraordinary Gentlemen can I
say it was a little bit of both well
despite a very strong performance by
Robert Downey jr. Sherlock Holmes as a
whole it kind of failed I mean the plot
and the story just felt disjointed and
hard to follow and not in that stylish
Guy Ritchie kind of way and that's Guy
Ritchie snatch and lock stock not Guy
Ritchie anything after that and in
thinking about it I think the reason the
movie felt like that is because they
don't tell you any of the clues being
picked up by Sherlock Holmes okay so
imagine national treasure where whenever
a new clue is found the clue is really
small and subtle enough to be missed by
we common folk we're talking it's like a
grain of chalk or a piece of lint or
something but in the movie they don't
tell you what clues were found or that
there were even any clues to be found
for that matter until the very end of
the movie don't worry no spoilers I'm
just saying it's a movie with room after
room and scenario after scenario of him
and gathering clues but you don't know
he's gathering clues and then he wraps
it all up in the last two minutes of the
movie which is supposed to bring
validity to the last hour and 58 minutes
you just watched and I suppose it does
but it just doesn't feel any more
fulfilling you're just kind of like
sweet Holmes like I would have liked to
have written that train with you but you
know thanks for leaving me in the dust
I was just officially a bystander in
this movie it's almost like it's a
method of storytelling that would have
worked for an hour-long episode of a TV
show or something but for a two-hour
movie just makes the whole thing feel
like a grind now for the good stuff I
absolutely loved Robert Downey jr. and
Guy Ritchie's take on the character
Sherlock Holmes he actually reminded me
a lot of Hugh Laurie is dr. house and on
a side note if you don't watch house you
really should Sherlock Holmes is
remarkably skilled at deductive
reasoning and I really liked how they
showed it in this movie like when he's
about to get into a fight he stops
thinks reasons and calculates the
statistics have damage inflicted on his
opponent and the probability of what his
opponents counter attack will be and the
best way to react accordingly it's a
really stylish way they do it in the
movie it was really cool because in
short he kills people with mathematics
how is that not awesome as for the
character Sherlock Holmes was awesome
Watson was pretty cool
probably because every scene he was in
he was with Sherlock awesome as for
Rachel McAdams
you don't really care much about her
character you don't know much about her
character you don't care much a better
character you know what you need to know
and that is that she is ridiculously hot
and that's that and in the world of plot
nitpicker age bear with me on this one
it's hard to make movies appealing but
they take place in 18-something and the
whole situation is that the world's
gonna be in peril like you know when
lord black woods all like i shall use
this obsolete technology to rule the
world we are from a time when splitting
the atom is just old news
so in Sherlock's all like my god Watson
a device that can controller the device
is through radio waves why that will
change the world whoever holds that
device shall have absolute apparently my
Sherlock sounds like Gandalf the Grey
but I mean you're just watching it going
wow I'm from a world where that device
has officially existed for decades now
and the world still here
yeah I don't think it's as damaging as
you think it might be so look think I
have his little remote control or
whatever the hell hey I said in the
world of nitpicker II in short the plot
characters and execution of the movie
fall short but Robert Downey jr.
absolutely owns the role of Sherlock
Holmes I would say watch the movie just
for him but since any second now a
bootleg collage of Robert Downey jr. as
great as Sherlock Holmes moments is
gonna hit the web I just say watch that
or I don't know you can always watch
avatar again but before you leave be
sure to click on the link on the sidebar
and subscribe to my channel because
there are more videos on the way many
more